We have to recognize that the classroom
is not the only place to learn.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann and today I wanna
talk about, you know, why you are the most
important person in language learning:
don't compare yourself to others.
Don't worry about others.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So, uh, you may have seen the video
that I put up where I tried to speak
20 languages, uh, sort of in one shot.
Um, obviously I messed up, uh, but
part of the purpose in doing that
was to show that we are going to
mess up when we speak languages.
It was pointed out for example, and I
immediately noticed that in Italian,
I said ... instead of ...  okay.
Easy enough to confuse
two romance languages.
Once more, I noticed that in my Korean, I
think I used ... which is very in Persian
and I started to use ... which is much
or many in Persian, again, in my Korean.
I can't remember all the other
places where I messed up.
if I thought about it, I would, but
of course, when I see that I would
like to redo it, but if I redo it,
I'll probably make a mistake somewhere
and this is a bit like when we use
the language that we're learning.
Sometimes we, we get it right one time and
then we don't get it right the next time.
And there are always people
who speak better than we do.
None of that matters.
You know, the brain is
gonna go where it goes.
Sometimes it'll go to the
right spot and it'll find the
word that you're looking for.
Sometimes it won't.
Sometimes it'll go to another language.
Uh, I've spent so much of the last three
months with Persian, my brain is kind
of, you know, a little bit twitchy,
uh, when it comes to looking for words,
it tends to go for a Persian word,
not a problem, you correct yourself.
Or the other person kind of
says, Hmm, what was that?
And then you continue communicating.
So it's very important that we put
ourselves at the, you know, at the sort
of focal point of our learning activity.
And as long as we feel that we're,
you know, enjoying the language
we think we're slowly improving.
Maybe some days we think we're no
longer improving, but we have to
remind ourselves that if we continue
to put in the time, we will improve,
as long as we engage with the language.
And in that regard, I thought it was
quite interesting the comment that I
received on my, uh, YouTube channel here,
where someone said that, uh, you know,
I used to be a fan of yours Steve, but
now as I learn more about linguistics,
educational psychology, and language
pedagogy, I realized the videos you
make and the methodology you promote are
inefficient at best and harmful at worst.
Poor ideas, just devaluing the classroom,
promoting your program, uh, misleading for
an audience that doesn't know any better.
And this person's a teacher.
Fine.
Uh, teachers are gonna defend the
classroom and there are undoubtedly
people who are good teachers and
people who learn in the classroom.
However, a lot of people find
the classroom frustrating.
A lot of people were turned off
language learning by the classroom.
Uh, at least in Canada, in the
English language school system, people
by and large don't learn French.
So we have to recognize that the
classroom is not the only place to learn.
In fact, I have found that in
trying to measure, you know, who
succeeds in language learning,
it's those people who do things
outside the classroom that succeed.
And what I promote here at my
channel is lots of input listening
and reading, that can't be bad.
Now, of course, I put in a plug for LingQ
here and there, but LingQ is not the
only place where you can listen and read.
But the basic principle that you have
to bring the language into you and that
until your brain has been exposed to
enough of, to enough of the language, the
grammar instruction is not going to work.
You know, if you're given, uh, you know,
so often when you're given, say road
instructions and you say yes, yes, yes.
And then it's completely gone because
you haven't been down that route
before you haven't been past the
post office to the intersection.
So until you've had some of that
experience if it's in your neighborhood
and they say, the store you're looking
for is located besides something
else and you know, the neighborhood,
then those instructions work.
But in languages, if you haven't
had enough of the language in you,
so that you're familiar with some
of the ways that the languages,
you know, the words come together.
The grammar instructions
are not that helpful.
And so linguistics, pedagogy, I have ne...
I have books, I bought books in behind
me on linguistics and teaching pedagogy.
I've never found them all that useful
because it's basically a personal journey.
If you're interested in the language,
you seek out content of interest,
a teacher can help you find the
content content of interest.
A teacher can stimulate that interest,
but you've gotta be interested.
And then you have to put in
the time, it's that simple.
It's not a matter of complicated pedagogy
and furthermore for this teacher to
suggest that the people who listen
to me simply don't know any better.
You know, I've had so many people tell
me, Steve, I never was able to learn a
language in the classroom, since listening
to you I have improved tremendously
since I started reading more, rather than
trying to speak more at an early stage.
Since I started listening more
I have better comprehension.
And lo and behold, now
I'm able to speak better.
So many people have said that to me.
I don't think those people are simply
people who don't know any better.
However, I understand that teachers
wanna protect what they're doing and
they want to feel, you know, that
what they're doing is valuable and it
can be valuable, particularly if the
teacher can motivate the learner to do
things, you know, on his or her own.
You know, and, and unfortunately, like I
mentioned before this language app that
the Canadian government put out called
Mauril or Mauril, uh, where basically
it's people creating comprehension
questions for, you know, Canadian like
CBC or Radio Canada television programs.
We don't need comprehension questions.
We don't need teachers
doing that sort of thing.
What we need is an ability to access
that content, put up all the transcripts
to the programs that, uh, CBC and Radio
Canada and people will be able to learn
from those because it's a personal.
So, and, and we need to compare
ourselves inevitably, some people
are going do better than others.
Some people will spend more time.
Some people will have
better pronunciation.
It doesn't matter.
It's always a personal journey.
It's up to you.
You're in charge.
You're steering the boat.
You go where you want to go
and don't worry about who's
behind you and who's ahead of.
Or who's trying to wave at you and
tell you, don't go there, go here.
It's a personal journey.
So there you have it.
That's my take on this idea of, of, you
know, always comparing yourself to others
or, or looking for approval from others.
Don't, it's your own personal journey.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.